top diplomats from G7 countries have
arrived in the Japanese city of
karawitawa for three days of talks the
war in Ukraine China's growing influence
in the region and North Korea's missile
tests are high in the agenda the talks
in an advance of G7 leaders Summits to
be held in Hiroshima next month's Robert
Price joining us from karusawa now we
know the Ukraine war is going to be top
of that agenda there are of course other
problems in the region as well Rob
[Music]
that's right I mean the work of this
Gathering really getting underway this
Sunday evening with a working dinner the
subject to which they'll be discussing
is the influence of China in this region
and The Wider world and also North Korea
all the participants have now arrived we
saw from James cleverley the British
foreign secretary he posted a selfie of
himself and his six colleagues arriving
on the specially charted
um Sheen canson the bullet train coming
from Tokyo it is all smiles no hint of
any uh disagreement but we do know that
there have been tensions in particular
in the approach of the G7 towards China
and especially on the in the wake of
Emmanuel macron the French president's
visit to Beijing seen by many of his G7
colleagues has been just a bit too
overly friendly with Xi Jinping given
that the U.S wants to try to rally the
Allies to counter the growing influence
of China in this part of the world World
which is not seen as a good thing by the
United States but so we're seeing from
the French foreign minister Kathleen
kolana a damage control at this Sunday
evening moving forward she is having to
outline the France's position when it
comes to dealing with China that uh she
is they are not uh breaking away from
the other European allies in particular
from the United States in fact she has
been tweeting that all of the G7 are
united when it comes to supporting a
free and open indo-pacific that's taken
as being aimed at China and at China's
intentions in this part of the the world
but in addition to all of the problems
in East Asia the Taiwan Strait South
China Sea North Korea and also the
problems in Europe with the Ukraine and
Russia we're also seeing of course the
problems in Africa are being taken front
and center with a deepening crisis in
Sudan from Antonio to Johnny the Italian
foreign minister he has tweeted that the
military leaders should cease are
immediately a sentiment echoed by Alina
bareback the German foreign minister
saying that she's appalled by the
casualties calling for an end to the
fighting Rob thank you very much indeed
that's Robert bright talking to us from
karawat Saba